[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au menu de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici le programme de ce
8 novembre
l'objectif dialoguer avec les acteurs de
la vie locale et construire
collectivement les politiques publiques
le département des Yvelines lance un
cycle de visite de terrain dans les
communes du territoire cette semaine le
président de la collectivité pierre
Bédié était un voisin le Bretonneux
Magny-les-Hameaux Coignières et
Chevreuse interview à suivre
s'élancer depuis un an et demi des
trottinettes électriques en
libre-service ont été déployés dans
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
depuis 1,2 millions de trajets ont été
effectués par les usagers de ce service
de la société tiers mobility premier
bilan du dispositif
et puis trappe un pro familier de retour
pour une septième édition Déclic Théâtre
vous donner rendez-vous le samedi 18
novembre à la Merise à Trappes
différentes générations de comédiens se
retrouveront dans la patinoire pour ce
match d'improvisation et on va en parler
justement sur ce plateau avec nourelie
Hakim Louise de l'Association des clics
théâtre bonsoir et vous êtes chargés du
secteur improvisation dans cette
association qui va bientôt fêter ses 30
ans en aura l'occasion d'en reparler
tout à l'heure trappeur pro family donc
qui va arriver le 18 novembre c'est un
peu une réunion de famille c'est
important de se réunir en famille chaque
année c'est l'idée c'est vraiment l'idée
de base c'est la réunion annuelle en
fait où c'est l'occasion de faire
revenir un petit peu toutes ces
personnes qu'on a rencontré dans les
différents voyages ou les différents
accueils qu'on a pu organiser est-ce que
vous allez laver votre linge sale en
famille justement le 19 c'est l'idée
c'est un match donc à un moment donné
forcément il va y avoir un peu de
compétition toute relative mais il va y
avoir un petit peu de ça et on en dira
bien sûr un peu plus tout à l'heure bien
sûr en plateau également les
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
Céline Charles bonsoir avec vous tout à
l'heure on va voir qu'il est possible
d'estimer le prix de son véhicule en
moins d'une minute oui Grégory plus
besoin d'aller dans un garage pour
estimer votre véhicule je vais vous
parler d'un nouveau concept à monter son
qui va vous permettre d'obtenir une
estimation de prix en moins d'une minute
et également un nouveau visage de la
rédaction TV 78 c'est Régine rage
bonsoir nouvelle journaliste donc de la
rédaction de tv78 à suivre avec vous les
informations du jour et on verra qu'il
ne fait pas toujours bon circuler en
Île-de-France en ce moment en culture
également en retour sur la 11e édition
et du festival metal sphère et
découverte du nouveau spectacle immersif
autour et de la Belle et la Bête c'est
au château de Maisons-Laffitte mais
avant tout cela coup d'oeil à votre
météo de demain
une journée de mercredi similaire à
celle d'aujourd'hui mardi le matin il
devrait y avoir quelques éclaircies avec
12 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles
et Houdan 11 degrés à Rambouillet
quelques averses sont annoncées dans
l'après-midi pour les températures
comptées 15 degrés à Houdan et
Mantes-la-Jolie à Versailles et
Rambouillet il fera à 14 degrés ce
mercredi 9 novembre nous fêterons les
Théodore
[Musique]
et on passe tout de suite aux
informations du jour je le disais avec
vous Régine ralech et on commence avec
le chiffre du jour oui et le chiffre du
jour c'est 67 parce que 67% du temps des
trajets des Franciliens est passé dans
les bouchons en 2022 et ce chiffre
provient de Coyote une entreprise de
système de navigation GPS pour se faire
elle s'est basée sur sa communauté de 5
millions d'utilisateurs alors plusieurs
facteurs expliquent cette congestion on
a d'une part les grèves de transport
mais il y a aussi les journées qui se
raccourcissent de plus en plus et qui
incitent les Franciliens à davantage
utiliser leur véhicule et donc peu de
recours au covoiturage
de la rédaction de TV 78 alors toujours
côté transport une nouvelle ligne de bus
a été mise en place dans les Yvelines
mise en service effectivement en fait
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour les
habitants du quartier Fauveau à
Villeneuve-sur-Seine il aura fallu
plusieurs mois de discussions entre la
municipalité et les acteurs des
transports pour que la ville gain de
cause en fait un arrêt a été ajouté sur
la ligne une et donc du coup pour le
moment on aura deux départs qui seront
prévues à l'arrêt Fauveau le matin en
direction de la gare de Villeneuve et
dans le sens inverse deux arrêts
également le soir
une info aussi que vous lis nous
partagez côté santé avec une nouveauté
qui va bientôt arriver effectivement à
partir du lundi 14 novembre les
pharmaciens pourront administrer des
vaccins et les rappels qui sont
prescrits par les médecins donc le but
c'est de soulager les professionnels de
santé mais également d'augmenter la
couverture vaccinale des adultes chaque
vaccination sera facturé à 7,50 € pour
des patients de plus de 16 ans dans les
prochains mois également il sera prévu
que les pharmaciens prescrivent
eux-mêmes les vaccins et inattendent
plus que le feu vert du Parlement pour
se faire on termine Régine avec l'image
du jour une image joyeuse effectivement
donc l'image du jour c'est la victoire
de la tenniswoman Caroline Garcia qui
est native de Saint-Germain-en-Laye elle
a remporté la nuit dernière au Texas le
master WTA contre la biélorus Arina
sabalenca le score donc c'est 7,6 et 6 4
c'est une immense performance pour la
joueuse qui est deuxième française a
remporté la compétition après Amélie
Mauresmo en
et par la même occasion donc Caroline
Garcia devient numéro 4 mondial
fantastique pour elle avec de nombreuses
victoires de tournois c'est une victoire
qui vous réjouit
de tennis un petit peu du plaisir dans
le fait de regarder du tennis je trouve
ça c'est un peu quelque chose qui est
resté voilà qui on avait on a perdu un
peu de de plaisir à regarder le tennis
et puis là c'est ça fait de nouvelles
têtes et puis en plus voilà une tête
française qui brille comme ça ça fait du
bien une bonne nouvelle côté sport et
alors si vous aussi vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité qui vous fait réagir
d'un fait près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous le dire et à le partager sur
nos réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news merci Régine rage pour
toutes ces précisions et on va passer à
présent à une première interview on le
disait tout à l'heure le président du
conseil départemental des Yvelines
pierre-bédie et les élus départementaux
ont lancé cette semaine une tournée des
cantons des visites de terrain pour
aller à la rencontre des acteurs du
territoire l'idée c'est de prendre la
température sur ces territoires
justement et de dialoguer pour nourrir
les futurs politiques publiques
départementales regardez cette interview
de Pierre Bédier collecté par Nicolas
dandry Patrick Jacques de dixmut pour
les moyens techniques nous sommes allés
à mairie de Coignières avec le président
du conseil départemental des Yvelines
pierre Bédié bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
venez de signer un contrat Yvelines plus
avec la mairie de Coignières en quoi
consiste ce contrat alors c'est un
contrat qui est le contrat cadre que
toutes les communes du département
peuvent demander au département en
l'espèce sur 5 millions d'euros de
dépenses la réflexion d'un groupe
scolaire un nouveau terrain enfin la
rénovation d'un terrain et une salle une
salle des fêtes
5 millions d'euros de dépenses le
département va subventionner de 1
million d'euros soit 20% de la dépense
j'imagine que le maire ira chercher
d'autres subventions ailleurs c'est une
façon pour les communes de pouvoir faire
plus grâce à l'aide du département en
quoi c'est important que le département
qu'il y ait cette solidarité entre les
collectivités parce que c'est notre âme
on a été créé pour ça lorsqu'elle
Révolution française on crée les
départements l'idée
des constituants c'est comme ils ont
avant créer les communes les communes
seules sont inégales il y a des grandes
des petites communes des communes
d'André territoire riche d'autres dans
des territoires pauvres et donc en ayant
un territoire plus vaste plus large avec
des revenus plus importants et bien il
pourra assurer une certaine égalité
entre ces communes c'est la fonction du
département donc on remplit cette
fonction j'ai la faiblesse de penser
qu'on le fait un peu plus dans les
Yvelines que dans d'autres départements
puisque dans notre budget
d'investissement les subventions
d'investissement aux communes sont le
premier poste budgétaire c'est donc
notre priorité un premier poste
budgétaire d'être direct aux communes
mais il y a aussi des aides indirectes
je pense notamment peut-être à l'agence
ingénierie à l'agence activity qui
contribue indirectement
chaque fois qu'on peut apporter une aide
aux communes on le fait principalement
un investissement parce que c'est le
mode de gestion du département qui se
résume en une formule radin surtout pour
être généreux sur l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est l'investissement parce
que l'investissement c'est pour les
générations actuelles et les générations
à venir et nous nous efforçons donc
chaque fois que c'est possible
d'apporter une aide aux communes comment
se fait le choix parce que je suppose
qu'il y a un peu plus de 200 communes
dans les Yvelines comment se fait le
choix parce qu'on peut pas distribuer à
tout le monde je suppose c'est toute la
difficulté d'exercice budgétaire il y a
259 communes et nous prévoyons une
enveloppe chaque année qui doit
correspondre à toutes les demandes qui
nous parviendront alors
s'il y a une année où on dépense un peu
plus ben on fera dans le cadre d'un
budget supplémentaire on abondera ce
budget investissement des communes
encore une fois c'est la priorité
on considère que les Yvelines
sont le département de la qualité de vie
quand on ne n'est pas Yves Linois on a
qu'une envie c'est venir dans les
Yvelines surtout quand on habite la
région parisienne et pour parvenir à ça
pour être ce territoire de la qualité de
vie on peut pas le faire tout seul nous
départementons il faut que les communes
soient engagées dans cette qualité de
vie et pour qu'elle puisse aussi engager
il faut une aide massive du département
c'est donc le sens de cette politique
alors pierre rester avec nous on va
juste écouter le maire de Coignières qui
va nous détailler justement les projets
qui vont être possibles rendu possible
rendu possible avec cette aide que vous
lui attribuez la première opération
porte sur la rénovation de l'école
Bouvet alors c'est une rénovation
thermique importante de cette école
c'est la construction aussi d'un nouveau
restaurant scolaire et c'est aussi sa
mise au norme PMR le deuxième projet
c'est une ère multisport
intergénérationnelle nous aurons donc
deux terrains de terrain de sport un
terrain de foot five un terrain de
basket un donc d'athlétisme et puis du
street workout c'est à dire un espace de
musculation et puis enfin le foyer rural
qui sera rénové et qui deviendra un
espace associatif et culturel là dont a
besoin aujourd'hui la commune et
toujours à la mairie de Coignières avec
le président du conseil départemental
des Yvelines pierre-bédier vous lancez
ce lundi 7 novembre la tournée des
cantons le département et vous en quoi
consiste ce concept
l'idée c'est que sur toi après cette
période un peu spéciale de covid de
confinement etc les liens se sont un peu
distendus on n'a pas forcément vu les
projets avancés on n'a pas eu le même
dialogue donc l'idée c'est resserrer ses
liens resserrer ces liens à l'intérieur
des Yvelines entre la commune et le
département entre les communes et le
département puis c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir voir des acteurs qu'on ne voit
pas autrement les élus on arrive à se
voir à travers un certain nombre de
manifestations mais on peut rencontrer
ça a été le cas lors du déjeuner des des
chefs d'entreprise des responsables
d'association sportive de commerce en et
puis voir aussi le travail que font
certaines associations j'ai passé un
moment absolument formidable avec une
association qui lutte contre les
violences morales donc c'est une façon
de mieux connaître le territoire pour
mieux appréhender les problèmes de ce
territoire pour trouver les meilleures
solutions possibles je crois beaucoup à
ce dialogue direct
on fait mieux quand on est sur place sur
le terrain que quand on est enfermé dans
un bureau quel bilan concrètement vous
faites de cette journée quelle demande
vous avez eu disons dans cette prise de
température
il y a pas de bilan en ce sens que
il y avait pas de demande de particulier
mais
c'est un sentiment pour moi de profonde
satisfaction d'abord parce que venir
voir sur place on a vu un voisin des
sujets de circulation venir le voir de
ses propres yeux c'est quand même
toujours plus pertinent pour ma forme
d'intelligence que de regarder ça dans
une note que quelqu'un vous a rédigé
avec des plans et puis j'avoue qu'à
titre personnel rencontrer rencontrer
des Yvelines noires engagés pour les
Yvelines heureux d'être dans les
Yvelines c'est bon pour le moral donc on
recommencera merci Pierre Bédié Merci à
VOUS président du conseil départemental
des Yvelines qui va poursuivre cette
tournée des cantons dans les prochaines
semaines
il y a un an et demi la société tiers
mobility déployée c'est trottinettes en
libre-service dans 12 communes de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec plus de
65000 clients le service dresse un
premier bon bilan le reportage de Julien
Leroy 1 million c'est le nombre de
trajets réalisés par les trottinettes
électriques tirent depuis leur lancement
à 50 ans en Yvelines en mai 2021 grâce à
une application mobile il est possible
de réserver facilement son véhicule 24
heures sur 24 un nouveau moyen de
transport qui a séduit plus de 65 000
clients dans l'agglomération plus de 75%
des utilisateurs aujourd'hui ce sont des
hommes donc on travaille aussi avec
l'opérateur à essayer de rééquilibrer la
tendance
jeune jeune c'est-à-dire entre 16 ans et
un peu plus de la trentaine plus de 1000
trottinettes principalement utilisées
pour des trajets domiciles travaillent
en intermodalité avec les gars SNCF de
l'agglomération la crise des carburants
de ces dernières semaines a permis une
augmentation du service de 20%. c'est un
territoire stratégique puisque nous
sommes en zone périurbaine ou encore 70%
des déplacements sont faites sont faits
en voiture individuelle il y a un vrai
intérêt à proposer des solutions comme
celle-ci qui sont flexibles pratiques en
libre-service j'utilise tout le temps
pour aller en cours ou sinon pour aller
chercher mes courses parce que ça va
plus vite les trottinettes ont une
vitesse bridée à 20 km/h et parfois à 10
km/h dans les zones les plus fréquentées
cet accident ont été relevé depuis
l'ouverture du service pour éviter une
amende de 25 euros les clients doivent
restituer leur trottinette dans l'une
des 300 stations ces pénalités n'empêche
pas la présence de certains véhicules
égarés le long des routes cette
utilisateur reproche le manque de
liberté causé par ce dispositif moi ce
matin ma trottinette personnelle à la
crevée donc j'en ai j'ai pris une tière
pour aller au travail mais il y a pas de
spot juste à côté
où on peut les on peut les laisser les
tiers et donc j'ai dû j'ai dû marcher un
peu quoi jusqu'au boulot mais bon fort
de son succès sur l'agglomération 56 la
société tir mobility a récemment élargi
une zone d'utilisation les trottinettes
ont été déployées à Saint-Cyr-l'École
Bois-d'Arcy et Buc désormais 40 communes
des Yvelines utilisent ce service
[Musique]
une petite question si vous faites
partie des 65000 utilisateurs de cette
trottinette électrique pas encore je
vous avoue que je préfère le vélo quand
même on les voit fleurir sur le
territoire même aux pieds de l'immeuble
de TV 70 on envoie souvent avec ces
trottinettes électriques alors justement
si on veut troquer sa voiture pour une
trottinette et qu'on veut vendre sa
voiture tout simplement vous allez nous
donner quelques astuces astuces avec une
innovation notamment c'est un scanner
qui estime le prix de rachat de son
véhicule et ce en quelques secondes pour
se pour se faire direction le parking du
magasin Carrefour de Montesson ce
dispositif est installé depuis le 10
octobre comment ça marche alors un
scanner géant 300 photos une
intelligence artificielle et en moins
d'une minute un prix de rachat de votre
véhicule c'est une sorte de petite
révolution du marché du véhicule
d'occasion proposé par prouve station
qui est le leader européen des solutions
d'inspection automobile assistée par
intelligence artificielle l'entreprise a
lancé un service innovant d'estimation
et de rachat de votre véhicule
c'est 100% gratuit sans rendez-vous est
disponible de 8h à 20h six jours sur 7
c'est sur le parking du Carrefour de
Montesson depuis le 10 octobre comme
vous l'avez dit Grégory il y en a pour
l'instant trois en France concrètement
comment ça fonctionne ce portique alors
c'est simple au volant de votre véhicule
vous pouvez d'abord passer par une borne
interactive qui va vous demander
quelques informations votre nom le
modèle de la voiture sans kilométrage et
ensuite vous avez juste à passer dans la
station une sorte de scanner géant qui
va venir réaliser un diagnostic
automatique de l'extérieur de votre
voiture en seulement trois secondes
carrosseries vitrage pneumatique ou
encore les optiques sont passés au
crible on écoute Cédric Bernard CIO et
cofondateur de l'entreprise sur le
mécanisme du portique vous avez une
dizaine de caméras en fait sur le
système qui vont prendre du coup
vraiment une vision 360 degrés de votre
véhicule pour connaître son état général
ici vous avez une arche lumineuse qui
permet en fait de fonctionner quel que
soit la saison l'heure en fait de la
journée si il fait nuit c'est pas grave
vous pouvez passer mais on reste de
toute façon opérationnelle et juste là
vous avez un système en fait qui est un
système donc magnétique qui permet
détecter en fait de manière automatique
l'épaisseur de la gomme que vous avez
sur le pneumatique donc c'est à dire on
vient détecter la partie usure et
géométrie potentiellement que vous allez
survé sur le véhicule et donc tout ça
alimente en fait une intelligence
artificielle qui vient traiter ces
informations pour les envoyer aux
professionnels qui permettent ensuite du
coup de prendre un engagement
vous pouvez ensuite aller faire vos
courses ou rentrer chez vous et vous
allez recevoir
par Emir
ici la voiture que l'on voit sur l'écran
qui date de 2014 à une estimation de
3000 euros alors l'offre elle est
valable pendant 7 jours bien sûr vous
êtes libre ou non d'accepter mais si
c'est le cas le contrat peut-être signé
directement en ligne il y a un service
joké offert c'est à dire que les centres
partenaires peuvent venir chercher la
voiture directement à votre domicile ou
bien au travail vous allez par la suite
recevoir directement l'argent sur votre
compte en seulement 24 heures par
virement bancaire donc ce concept était
réservé depuis trois ans aux
professionnels de l'automobile
constructeur concessionnaire loueur et
les particuliers peuvent en bénéficier
depuis l'été on écoute à nouveau Cédric
Bernard sur les objectifs du dispositif
ou vous débrouiller par vous même elle
est la vente sur les plateformes en
ligne type leboncoin etc donc bon on est
toutes les contraintes les risques de
fraude le temps que ça va vous prendre
le fait que vous n'avez pas forcément
envie de recevoir chez vous plein de
monde etc ou d'aller le vendre
professionnel pour le vendre
professionnel il faut un prendre
rendez-vous adapter votre agenda au
leurre donc c'est énormément une grosse
consommation de temps le prix il varie
énormément en fonction du professionnel
que vous allez voir nous on a changé un
peu ce procédé c'est une énorme économie
de temps c'est aussi ça permet de faire
des prix aussi également très
compétitifs puisque voilà cette vision
en fait impartiale qui est donnée du
véhicule permet également aux
professionnels de s'engager alors le CEO
dit bien qu'il y a 0 pression et
contrainte puisqu'il n'y a au plus
aucune obligation de vente 1000 voitures
passent par ce portique par mois et un
dernier chiffre pour terminer il faut
savoir que 10% des gens qui passent
devant ce dispositif ont comme projet de
revendre leur véhicule merci Céline pour
la découverte de ce dispositif qui est
installé à monter son alors toujours au
chapitre économique il y a le prochain
numéro de l'émission skyco à suivre
cette semaine sur TV 78 ce sera vendredi
à 18h30 Nicolas dandry vous fera
découvrir notamment l'entreprise et leur
man tyton cette société est installée à
Trappes depuis une trentaine d'années
elle est spécialisée et dans la
production de produits plastiques pour
fixer et protéger les câbles industriels
elle vient d'investir dans de nouvelles
machines regardez cet extrait
le centre tout nouveau de recherche et
de développement vous voyez c'est très
propre parce que on a trois presses
complètement nouvelles après c'est
injecter du plastique de 60 tonnes 100
tonnes et 200 tonnes où on va pouvoir
travailler en environnement sale grise
voire même sale blanche donc on est sur
des exigences en termes de particules et
de pollution assez élevée et ce texte
Center va pouvoir nous aider à
travailler en innovation pour mieux
servir encore nos clients par rapport à
des besoins qu'ils ont déjà exprimés et
des besoins qui n'ont pas encore exprimé
et on va les leur faire comprendre de
façon à se différencier par rapport à la
concurrence et justement garder notre
activité ici sur 50 ans en Yvelines
alors par rapport à ce texte Center
quels sont les objectifs à la fois
stratégiques et technologiques ok alors
en lien avec le texte Center notre
ambition c'est de développer des
nouvelles pièces c'est notre première
objectif donc ça va nous permettre de
tester des nouveaux design des nouveaux
moules des nouvelles matières ça c'est
vraiment très important on va être
encore plus respectueux de
l'environnement donc des nouvelles
matières
des nouveaux processus on travaille sur
les réglages que après on va pouvoir
dupliquer à notre
outil industriel à notre centre de
production ce sont des presses
électriques donc pas hydrauliques donc
c'est mieux pour l'environnement et
effectivement en premier lieu on va
pouvoir utiliser une partie de nos
rebroyés qui viennent de la production
donc ce sont de la matière plastique qui
n'a pas été utilisée ou qui a été
utilisé mais qu'on peut réutiliser une
nouvelle fois et on va pouvoir faire des
des essais grâce à ses presses là pour
réutiliser cela après en production et
être moins consommateur de matière et
donc d'énergie
[Musique]
la liberté égalité fraternité improvisée
Déclic Théâtre vous donne un rendez-vous
le vendredi à 18 novembre pour sa
septième édition de trappe un pro family
différentes générations de comédiens
vont se retrouver sur scène ou plutôt au
cœur de la patinoire pour un grand match
et d'improvisation on en parle on le
disait tout à l'heure avec noeliakine
Louise chargé du secteur improvisation à
Déclic Théâtre vous serez d'ailleurs
l'arbitre de cette soirée trappe en
profits en le disant préambule tout à
l'heure c'est un peu le grand
rendez-vous de rentrée de la rentrée à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour Déclic
Théâtre même si la rentrée est passée
depuis quelques semaines déjà on a déjà
fait quelques quelques petites choses
enfin des grosses choses même dans la
mesure où on a on a monté un spectacle
qu'on a joué au lycée de la plaine de
naufle qui s'appelle le théâtre Express
on travaille sur les
sur les œuvres qui vont être étudiées
par les élèves de Première au bac
français
mettra pas pour family oui c'est un
rendez-vous maintenant habituel de
Marseille ouais installer qui a passé
l'épreuve du covid qui revient
donc c'est la septième édition et oui on
c'est un peu notre ouverture de saison
autour du match d'improvisation savoir
qu'on commence à jouer des matchs en
général au mois de janvier et après tout
le long et tout le reste de la saison
mais c'est le premier moment où on
essaye aussi beaucoup de faire venir
les élèves qui sont inscrits aux
ateliers et qui vont découvrir le match
d'improvisation en tant que joueur et
qu'il a en fait pour eux c'est aussi
l'occasion de venir voir un match en
vrai avec leur coachs et puis en grande
pompe parce que des clips théâtre on le
rappelle une association qui a bientôt
30 ans ce sera les 30 ans de déclic
l'année prochaine à un axe fort un axe
principal autour de l'improvisation
théâtrale alors beaucoup connaissent sur
le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines le
principe du match d'improvisation mais
quels sont les grandes règles du match
d'improvisation que faut-il savoir alors
la règle principale c'est ça c'est pas
une règle c'est c'est c'est un principe
le principe c'est qu'on vient pour
s'amuser et pour se faire plaisir ça bon
quand on a dit ça c'est un peu facile
mais après il y a des règles oui parce
qu'on essaie de raconter aussi des
belles choses dans cet espace de jeu et
donc pour raconter des belles choses ben
les règles sont simples c'est qu'il faut
que les histoires soient claires
compréhensibles
qui est de l'enjeu dans ce qu'on raconte
et puis et puis qu'on qu'on soit dans
dans un parfait échange avec le public
c'est super cette date parce que le
public revient d'aller en année et là
j'ai vu les comptes aujourd'hui à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui on est à 570
personnes
il reste quelques places mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que il y a
vraiment cette rencontre et ce et cette
échange pardon qui sait avec entre les
comédiens et la communion avec le public
d'autre je suis un peu le retour l'année
dernière de la septième c'était la 6e
édition même l'année dernière et après
le covid on se souvient qu'il y avait eu
bien sûr une grande attente autour de de
ce rendez-vous d'ailleurs on a vu sur
les images et aussi une métaphore
sportive la métaphore du hockey sur
glace puisqu'il y a la patinoire c'est
là que se passe le match d'improvisation
il y a des tenues aussi qui sont proches
de celle du hockey sur glace c'est la
légende dit qu'en fait les comédiens
québécois gravaient les Leduc on vu les
salles de théâtre ce je dis que c'est
une légende parce qu'on sait jamais trop
sur quoi différente légendes il y a
différentes légendes il y a différentes
manières de raconter nous on dit que
voilà quand la NHL a commencé à
s'installer le tournoi de hockey en
Amérique on sait que le sport américain
prend beaucoup de place dans la vie des
des des outres atlantiques si je puis
dire et du coup on a quelque chose voilà
qui qui s'est mis en place pour faire un
pied de nez au hommage de hockey sur sur
scène sur une scène théâtrale avec
différentes générations de comédiens qui
seront réunies ont rigolait après sur ça
tout à l'heure c'est un peu la réunion
de famille finalement c'est toutes ces
années de déclic réunis sur sur scène
ouais et puis surtout alors c'est c'est
toutes ces toutes ces formations qu'on a
qu'on a pu suivre sur les 30 dernières
années donc le le cru entre guillemets
de de 50 ans en Yvelines de trappes et
des improvisateurs qu'on a rencontré
pour la plupart dans les établissements
scolaires qui sont aujourd'hui des
comédiens professionnels et aguerris à
pleins de disciplines différentes et
puis aussi
on a kenzam qui va venir de l'île de la
Réunion qui est un comédien qu'on a
rencontré en 2004 la première fois
on se revoit toutes ces années quand il
vient en France quand il nous invite on
arrive à créer des choses avec Roberto
CIRA qui va venir jouer aussi qui a un
comédien québécois
qu'on rencontre sur le Mondial
d'improvisation junior qu'on joue avec
les Belges et les Suisses donc on se
voit tous les ans et c'est inamitié
forte et intéressante et en plus c'est
quelqu'un qui a joué à trappe dans les
premiers tournois qui ont été organisés
à Trappes en 1991 donc voilà on essaye
d'écrire aussi et de se raconter un peu
une histoire comme ça au fur et à mesure
des années avec les gens qui sont là on
essaye de la réinventer à chaque fois à
chaque trappe à family et puis surtout
c'est dire aux comédiens les plus jeunes
il y en a eu d'autres aussi avant nous
voilà il y a des il y a des il y a des
ponts à faire avec avec toutes ces
personnalités qui sont voilà qui sont
intéressantes et qu'on a envie de
présenter à la ville et qui composent
justement le reste de cette famille de
la trappe un prof family pour cette 7e
édition très peu family en fait ça a pas
ça a pas de limite c'est à dire qu'il y
a on sait c'est des histoires de cercle
donc on a un premier cercle de comédien
qui travaille au quotidien on en a un
deuxième de comédien qui ont peut-être
une autre activité plus légère auprès de
la comédie de la compagnie mais il y a
aussi l'improvisation le match
d'improvisation ça permet ça ça permet
de jouer avec d'autres personnes
excusez-moi je m'étouffé décidément je
crois que c'est passé mais en tout cas
c'est ouais c'est une pratique qui
permet en fait de rencontrer des gens
dans dans
sans être dans dans quelque chose
d'agressif on est là pour pour être pour
être ensemble pour se dire oui dans la
patinoire et puis pour raconter des
histoires ensemble donc finalement on et
puis c'est une passion je veux dire le
match d'impro quand quelqu'un d'autre la
partage on n'est pas très nombreux en
France finalement on est content de les
avoir et puis on les garde au plus près
de nous je disais vous serez l'arbitre
de la soirée comment ça va se dérouler
est-ce qu'il y aura un match plusieurs
matchs d'improvisation non c'est un
match c'est un casting c'est un match
classique alors moi j'aime bien dire
classique parce que le machinisation il
peut prendre plusieurs formes et des
formes très différentes il a beaucoup
évolué mais là on est dans quelque chose
d'assez proche de de de de ce qui a
existé dans les années 80 et dans la
création du match même si voilà on a
aussi nos notre manière de de l'aborder
et donc on va voir des des catégories
très musicales cette année parce que je
sais qu'il y en a beaucoup qui aiment
chanter on va avoir des des ouais ouais
bon ça va être un match très classique
il va pas y avoir de il va y avoir de la
surprise mais mais qui qui qui va être
dans les histoires en fait on va voir
des choses qui vont se passer
c'est dur d'en parler c'est de l'impro
oui donc
dans la manière on va amener le match en
tout cas on va être on va être sur
quelque chose d'assez on va pas mentir
au public voilà nous on l'aime le faire
comme ça et c'est comme ça qu'on va le
présenter et on est tout proche de cette
ce 30e anniversaire de Déclic Théâtre
compagnie fondée en 1993 par Alain
Degois et Jean-Baptiste Chauvin on
rappelle les grands noms qui ont débuté
forcément il y en a beaucoup un Jamel
Debbouze sofiara Marnot de sa mère il sa
Doumbia Laurie Péret Matthieu longuette
pour ne citer pour me citer que c'est
dans un coin de votre tête déjà c'est
30e anniversaire
alors pour l'instant je vais vous dire
la vérité c'est vraiment dans un coin de
la terre on le sait que on va devoir
faire ça mais après on a une activité
très riche et très palpitante de manière
assez quotidienne cette année on
accueille les Mondiaux aussi
d'improvisation junior ça sera ça la
première semaine de des vacances de
février donc voilà il va y avoir des
événements comme ça donc oui on est déjà
en train de mettre les premiers les
premiers jalons mais mais pour l'instant
on n'a pas encore voilà on y travaille
et puis ça sera le moment de d'appuyer
sur le champignon on saura faire merci
nous d'être venu en parler en plateau
trap un prof family 7e édition c'est
donc au programme à la Meurice de
Trappes le vendredi 18 novembre et je
vous lisais un différente générations de
comédiens vont se retrouver sur scène ou
plutôt au cœur même de la patinoire pour
ce grand match d'improvisation vous
lisez tout à l'heure il reste quelques
places à les tarifs pour les Trappistes
tu arrives plein à 12 euros réduit à 7
euros et pour les extérieurs tu arrives
plein à 19 euros et tarif réduit à 12
euros toutes les informations sur le
site de
kiosque.sqy.fr cette exposition à
présent à l'occasion du 52e anniversaire
de la disparition du général de Gaulle
Charles de Gaulle l'homme derrière le
général à l'espace Arnaud Beltrame de
Poissy c'est jusqu'au 20 novembre elle
propose de redécouvrir cette
personnalité emblématique et comprendre
l'homme derrière la figure historique du
20e siècle inauguration de l'exposition
demain mercredi 9 novembre à 19h juste
avant à 18h un hommage sera rendu devant
au général de Gaulle pardon devant le la
stèle de l'octroi et c'est à Poissy bien
sûr et du 18 novembre au 18 décembre
plongés dans la féerie du comte de La
Belle et la Bête au château de
Maisons-Laffitte la société de
production Polaris organise un spectacle
immersif avec 8 décors de cinéma vin
comédiens 24 danseurs et 500 bénévoles
Mathilde Franco et Julien Leroy ont pu
assister à l'une des répétitions
générales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois dans un pays lointain
un jeune prince qui vivait dans un
château
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces quelques mots vous disent peut-être
quelque chose la société de production
Polaris revient dans les Yvelines avec
un tout nouveau spectacle immersif sur
le compte de la Belle et la Bête au
château de Maisons-Laffitte en plus des
décors et des costumes on invite les
spectateurs à se glisser dans les scènes
donc c'est des espaces qui sont parfois
un peu étroits un peu petits on va
passer par des escaliers secrets en
colimaçon des lieux que le public ne
visite habituellement pas c'est un
château qui nous permet vraiment de
faire vivre le conte de la Belle et la
Bête en fait voilà les espaces
s'adaptent très bien à ce compte par
exemple la salle de Bâle qui est très
très belle avec avec ses lustres etc au
total 500 volontaires et comédiens
professionnels seront présents pour vous
plonger dans un univers féérique pour
rendre la magie possible il y a plus de
six groupes en fait de comédiens d'une
centaine de comédiens qui vont se
relayer du matin jusqu'au soir le
spectacle commence à 9 heures il se
termine à minuit il ne s'arrête jamais
[Musique]
alors moi je suis dans les cuisines et
je donnerai pas mon rôle c'est une
surprise comme ça ça vous invite à venir
voir le spectacle pour moi c'est une
première j'ai fait un peu de théâtre et
j'aime ça d'ailleurs mais c'est la
première fois que je joue pour Polaris
et je pense pas que ça soit la dernière
je vis un rêve de petite fille c'est à
dire que je vais danser pendant le bal
avec La Belle et la Bête et pour moi
c'est exceptionnel c'est je pense la
seule fois de ma vie où je pourrais
danser dans le château de
Maisons-Laffitte en partenariat avec le
Centre des monuments nationaux le
spectacle aura lieu sur quatre semaines
du 18 novembre au 18 décembre l'occasion
de vérifier si le vécure bien heureux
pour toujours
[Musique]
les enceintes ont vibré fort ce week-end
à Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec le festival
la métal sphère une onzième édition sur
laquelle reviennent et Gabriel Gontier
et Julien le roi
le métal a enflammé la scène ce week-end
à Voisins-le-Bretonneux pour la 11e
édition metasos s'associe à la salle de
la tour pour promouvoir la culture métal
dans les Yvelines
[Applaudissements]
parmi les nombreux artistes présents
Clem du groupe ashion pour qui le
festival est une première on fait un
métal type métal corps c'est une musique
relativement agressive avec des
alternances entre des passages très
mélodiques des passages voilà un peu de
musique électronique et puis des gros
breakdance comme on adore quoi
et eux aussi adore ils étaient prêts de
400 spectateurs ce week-end certains
chanceux ont pu échanger avec les
artistes
une bonne programmation et puis c'est
une bonne ambiance
et puis les groupes ils sont super
accessibles un festival à la hauteur de
ce style musical en perpétuelle
évolution après une édition en mars 2022
le festival est un succès pour metasos
l'association organisatrice présente
depuis 20 ans sur le territoire c'est un
festival qui s'installe on a un public
un peu d'habituer qui connaissent le nom
et donc elle se développe de plus en
plus et donc très content de pouvoir
organiser voilà ce festival avec des
groupes de qu'on apprécie qu'on aime
faire découvrir au public
d'autres rendez-vous sont à prévoir pour
les métalux et pour les curieux le but
faire découvrir une culture différente
et des styles alternatifs loin des
clichés
[Musique]
avant de vous laisser on refait un
dernier point sur la météo de demain
[Musique]
avec une journée de mercredi similaire à
celle d'aujourd'hui le matin il devrait
y avoir quelques éclaircies avec 12
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Houdan 11 degrés à Rambouillet des
averses sont annoncées dans l'après-midi
pour les températures comptées 15 degrés
à Houdan et Mantes-la-Jolie à Versailles
Rambouillet il fera 14 degrés ce
mercredi 9 novembre nous fêterons les
Théodore voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
bien sûr demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]